(upbeat orchestral music)
(audience cheering)
[Andy] Coming to you from
the historic Largo Theater
in Hollywood, it's Conan!
I'm Andy Richter.
Tonight, Will Ferrell!
Now, here he is!
Conan O'Brien!
(audience applauding)
(silence)
Hey. Conan O'Brien here.
Let me briefly explain where I am.
Right now I'm sitting in
the iconic Largo Theater.
Why am I here?
Well, a lotta theaters across the country
are struggling right now,
and we really wanted to help
one of the local empty
theaters here in Los Angeles.
So we chose Largo.
Largo's a very special place to everyone
in the Los Angeles comedy community.
Just about everybody's performed here.
And here's a fun fact: I
started here doing improv.
That's right, I got my
first laughs here in 1985.
And got my last laughs here in 1991.
No laughs since. Bit of
a drought. (chuckles)
No, me laughing at myself doesn't count.
Anyway, let me assure you we are following
all of the health protocols
while we're here at the Largo.
I'm here with a bare-bones crew.
Everyone's wearing a mask,
everyone's socially distanced,
and the theater itself
is completely empty.
In fact, the only person
sitting here tonight
is my assistant Sona.
Hey Sona!
[Sona] Hi!
[Conan] How's it goin'?
[Sona] All right.
See, I'm gonna feed off Sona's energy.
I'm gonna take that energy
and ride it like a wave,
and that's gonna give me the
energy I need to entertain you.
And you know, there's
another reason, actually,
that we moved locations.
Like a lotta people across the
country, probably like you,
I've been inside my home with
my family for months now,
and I thought it would be
nice to kinda switch it up.
So this is actually my
first time away from my wife
since the quarantine started.
So I just wanna briefly check in,
see how she's doing without me.
♪ He's gone, he's gone,
he's finally gone ♪
[Conan's Wife] (laughing) Woo-hoo!
Oh, thank god! (cackles)
Oh.
Well, she'll cheer up
eventually. (chuckles)
Anyway, given everything
that's happening right now
on our planet, just...
We're dealing with a lot.
Let's face it: Sometimes
you just need to escape.
Well, luckily, our newest
sponsor has you covered.
Take a look.
[Reporter] A heartbreaking milestone.
Nearly 100,000 lives lost
to the coronavirus pandemic.
[Reporter] Killer hornets
invading the U.S. and Canada.
(grenades booming)
(crowd yelling)
(somber music)
(record scratches)
[Narrator] Wanna get away? Now you can.
SpaceX will soon be offering
trips to outer space.
SpaceX.
You are now free to leave this hellhole.
Thank you, good people at SpaceX.
Anyway, we got a great show tonight.
Will Ferrell is gonna be joining us.
Excited about that, Sona?
[Sona] Yeah.
Will Ferrell.